hey guys it is Friday which means we're
here to tell you about the five biggest
things that happened in gaming this week
or just the stories we spotted that we
wanted to talk about if there's a story
we don't mention that you want to talk
about be sure to put it in the comment
section below but for now here's what
I've got for you you should say
something I just sit on the web okay so
nobody likes piracy but we as consumers
tend to not like DRM either and when
they Sega came out saying that Sonic
mania was going to have the de nouveaux
anti-tamper software on it when the
steam page previously did not list any
such things it upset a lot of people it
did but it's now been cracked so don't
worry about it well it's been cracked
but if you were to pirate it if you're
confident definitely because the very
game but it's been cracked took eight
days yeah it took eight days to crack
which is still not the fastest a game
has been cracked that goes to Tekken 7
which was cracked in a matter of four
days and then after that was Ryan which
was five days that's right and Resident
Evil 7 also took five days I mean of
course we don't endorse piracy but it's
interesting that a few of those games
got to a point particularly Brian where
once it had been cracked the developers
just tore a software off their well
what's the point you know the whole
point is it's anti-tamper
and you know what's doing nothing
nullified there's no point having it on
there so now that sonic mania has been
cracked this question about whether
that's gonna happen for Sager as well
whether they're gonna take the de
nouveaux software off do let us know
what you think about the RM in that
comment box and in the meantime please
enjoy this entertaining tweet from
doodle Gamescom who tweeted back to the
PR manager of sonic mania asking for
feedback on DRM dan you played American
McGee's Alice I have I'm gonna play the
first one and it's not great
I played madness Returns I played the
first two I play the first ten minutes
of madness returns and that was like a
market improvement I think a problem
with the first Ellis game is it's been
hell I'm going to come out like twelve
years ago it's nice
I'm way longer than that far well the
sequel came out in two
eleven I'm a big fans of both games I
love those balls I love those characters
in the reason we're talking about it is
that American McGee has come out and
said he's interested in making a third
game this is after years of him saying
there's nothing I can do stop asking me
to make another game owns the rights it
looks like he's gonna try and pitch a
new game to EA Alice three hey what
she's good which is tentatively calling
Alice's on yeah the series got like a
whole document that he wants to put
together with artwork and design plans
and outline of outline of what the games
gonna be and like kind of specs on what
he thinks financially it's gonna be
required in just a general business plan
so the point is if they can get that
together and it looks like it's gonna
work from his perspective they'll send
it off to EA and of course I think it's
true knows maybe there'll be more Alice
but maybe I can play the third one I do
but I'd really like to play an ALICE cam
when it comes out that would that would
be really exciting because they've got
some absolutely wonderful design yeah
it's really awesome and I mean if you're
really excited about it dan appears to
be low-to-medium excited I'm very
excited but if you're very excited as
well there is a mailing list so you can
join if you want to express your support
it looks like Americans trying to prove
that there's still an audience out there
for Alice games and when we did mention
this earlier in the week you guys seem
crazy excited which is right because I
thought this was a really underground
game so Dan it's destiny week and
everyone is playing destiny make sure
I'm playing too much of it I was up
until 10:30 p.m. way past my bedtime at
9 p.m.
playing last night but the nightfall
strike we know what it's going to be
this week the modifiers have been
revealed of what the strike is going to
be and there's also three challenges
that you can achieve when you do the
nightfall so here's what for those who
don't know what a nightfall is a
nightfall is a super hard version of an
existing strike with a bunch of
modifiers involved so I think like
skulls from Halo where you can do it'll
have like more enemies or enemies are
only vulnerable to headshots stuff like
that so this week the nightfall strike
is the arms dealer in which you need to
shut down the operations of an
ironmonger providing weapons to the red
Legion I don't know what that means it
sounds pretty fun though
but the modifiers are the exciting part
in this week the modifiers are some new
ones there's prism so the way prism
works is attacks that match the focus
element to increase damage and attacks
that don't match the focus element don't
do damage let me put that in people
is the focus element I don't know what
is so if a dude's got a blue shield and
you shoot him with a with a gun that has
a blue element yeah you're gonna who's
gonna hurt him more if you're shooting
with the one that's got a red element or
orange one that's solar it's not gonna
hurt him too bad the other other new
modifier is called time warp which puts
the nightfall on a timer and the only
way to extend the timer is to get kills
of enemies up to a certain point so
that's pretty cool and that actually
feeds into some of the challenges one of
the challenges tasks you with completing
the nightfall with five minutes left on
the clock
and then there's unbroken in which you
have to finish the nightfall with less
than three deaths and finally trash the
Thresher in which you have to take down
a thresher during one of the fights and
an order thresher is so if you guys are
interested in partying up and just to
remind everyone for the night falls make
sure you've partied up before you start
because anyone who jumps into a night
fall in progress might not get rewards
that's a bug that Bungie as well and
they're gonna be looking at fixing in
the next in the coming weeks and days
and stuff but oh yeah party up get on
that nightfall but I'm just say about
40% of what you just said well that's
great that's face off space students all
last weekend all I did was play the Call
of Duty World War 2 beta and it was a it
was quite different from the first
weekend so that was the second week at
the second and final weekend of the
closed beta for Call of Duty World War
two
sledgehammer games made a bunch of
changes and it looks like they're gonna
be taking all the feedback they've got
from that and putting those changes in
for the poor release of the game so in
the second weekend for Team Deathmatch
they made some changes they were up to
the US core limit from 75 to 100 and
they found that a lot of people weren't
actually reaching that kill women I mean
I was in a lot of games of team
deathmatch that didn't ever come close
to getting to that hundred score limit
so they're looking at bringing that back
down to 75 but they are waiting on
feedback they're also looking at
changing the time that it takes from
sprinting to then aim-down-sights of
your weapon because as it stands now it
was actually too slow so a lot of people
found that they'll running around like
madmen they couldn't get their guns up
high fast enough and I saw someone named
if anyone was camping they'd take him
out fast so it kind of rewarded that
camping slower paced gameplay which is
not really what you wanted
and the new Aachen map drew some
criticism for its lack of long
sightlines it only had medium sight
lines it was more of a close quarters
map but they're looking at changing that
but again all of this is they haven't
they haven't said exactly what they're
going to change so it sounds like it's
gonna be a bit more because I still got
some time until it comes out on in
November so there's gonna be a bit more
changes to multiplayer to hopefully make
it what you guys are all after Jess
what's Mario ah Mario is a Red Hat
plumber man if you go to a costume shop
the carnival what the licensing I'll
tell you what he's not what he's not a
plumber well plumber was one of the
things I just said that's shocking
they're gonna have to redo that non
licensed name they absolutely are
Nintendo has updated their Japanese
website to say Mario was no longer a
plumber he just does anything cool but
he's in pipes all the time well that you
see the way came about according to
Shigeru Miyamoto is the reason why they
said it was a plumber was because a lot
of the sections in Super Mario Brothers
had him underground so they were like oh
he's a plumber in Donkey Kong for
instance he was a carpenter in Mario
Kart he's I guess a cog in Mario Rabbids
Kingdom battle he is a murderer um yeah
but basically I think they're trying to
remove themselves from the plumber
aesthetic maybe plumbers aren't cool
anymore well I mean cause the operative
word because the the rewritten
description of his character just says
like Mario's all Browns 40 he's a tennis
player he's like into all the cool
sports and he's he does everything cool
it's basically reads like Mario's tinder
profile which I'm not super down with
I've got to remind everybody that Mario
is a portly masseur gentleman who
dresses up as a cat and walks around in
all fours in one of the games so you
know not sure if that's super cool isn't
it I don't know look at dresses up as
Abby climbs all over a giant B Mario
coolest guy out there I mean is Mario
cool I think this is a good question I
think he's pretty cool
no Mario is not cool Mario is not at all
cool I'm so cheery Mario you don't say
what's a girl like that the cool one the
cool one is definitely the way G because
he's there he's always he's away from
the spotlight Luigi's
opposite of cool no way man Luigi's like
he's like I think we just got some quiet
confidence to him I agree that he's a
king on the dog and I'm for a Luigi as
well but like for what is cool like
Louise she's not popular excuse me
no one likes Luigi in mario kingdom
Rabbids the rabbits can't even remember
he's never sorry toad can't even
remember his name he calls him Lewis
Lewis so I don't know why I don't know
where to land on this frankly I think
Mario's never actually held a job in his
life I think he's just some sort of
collecting some sort of welfare the doll
as we call it in Australia he's down
there every Thursday with his can of
coke getting his check and then got went
off on crazy adventures with his with
his friends down in the Mushroom Kingdom
but let us know what you reckon do you
think Mario's still lil Mario always be
a plumber to you or will he is he now
just the coolest man in the world that's
everything we have for you this week so
enjoy your weekend it's gonna be a
lovely weekend down here in Australia
and I hope it's lovely everywhere else
we'll be back on Monday and you can
subscribe to see us every day of the
working week for all the news you'll
have Nev the Mario Brothers and
Plumbing's their game they don't like
the others to get all the fame if your
sinks in trouble you can call them on
the double and pretty soon you'll be
hooked on the brothers that rap now
woefully factually incorrect Nintendo's
changed
Mario's profession from plumber to
anything cool why am I talking like this